donc j l'écho ce que cette boule de leur
cas et là j'ai une magnifique surprise
peau j'ai trouvé le cadeau qu'il te fall
est ce que tu veux un premier indice
mais regarde
jean rachid de genève la brenaz aussi
jeudi cette phrase l'amour c'est comme
un gros rhume ça s'attrape dans la rue
et ça se finit au lit homère héros stomy
bugzy mon frère notre frère luc en plus
finir et est ce que tu vois que moi ce
tome i et notre frère veut parler
là on sait tout de toi ou on le sait ce
que tu vas deuxième indice
voilà ce que tu reconnais cette photo
cette photo floutée
voilà bah oui bah oui c'est qui
et
ma première fiancée la première fiancée
et ça c'est toi là d'abord là ouais mais
flou été floutés c'est ta première
fiancée de passage s'est retiré est ce
qu'on peut avoir
un beau jour de la surprise
c'est une personne
bon jour pour nous bonjour
ce que vous pouvez nous redire bonjour
bonjour bonjour tu reconnais cette voie
non est ce que tu sais qui est cette
personne
vous allez faire venir un fou ou un truc
comme ça c'est une vraie vraie surprise
puisque c'est quelqu'un qui est venu de
dire quelque chose
c'est vrai oui on a retrouvé
oui qui était sur tes genoux la whey ton
premier amour c'est vrai ouais et bien
ton premier amour et là ce soir
zac à la pudeur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est alors c'est vrai premier amour
vous être magnifique bonsoir sa caméra
avec nous alors alors bruno lebel même
si vous êtes la première petite amie de
doc d'eau qu'est ce que ça te fait
quelque chose que tu es heureux de la
revoir toujours oui ça fait énormément
plaisir tu l'a pas revu depuis combien
de temps quelques années moment c'est en
quelle année ça ça fait combien de temps
accès à peu près ça 15 à ça ça fait 15
ans 15 ans ouais posté sa première souci
de dates à cette photo date d'hier
vous n'êtes pas vu depuis quinze ans
mais c'était son premier amour c'est à
quel âge on avec l'âge on va avec elle a
15 ans et 15 ans et comment vous êtes
combien peut être à l'aise et bien sûr
il est alors vous êtes connu comment est
ce parce que lui il se rappelle plus
propres à alonso qui a aussi cogné aux
puces de clignancourt au plus de clients
emploi vous faisiez quoi je faisais je
faisais le dimanche allait souvent opus
aller loin et lui faisait quoi il était
assis à l'entrée du passé sinon à faire
sur un trottoir par terre sur un trou
noir
c'était donc bien lieu et donc il est
d'accord on sait pas ça il est ex tony
way et ils m'ont suivi en fait et après
j'étais avec une amie j'ai dit à mon ami
si jamais il arrivait à nous dis leur
que je suis sourde et muette et alors
ils sont arrivés vers vous ce qui s'est
passé
ils vont il m'a fait rire tout de suite
c'est vrai il a dit quoi tu veux boire
quelque chose ce serait un truc comme ça
n'attaque tu le dis quoi d'autre
j'ai parlé langage des signes tout de
suite oui c'est vrai mais si c'est
parler langage des signes et vous êtes
ensuite voulu la revoir je l'aimé tout
de suite auprès des regards dans la lah
alors il y avait pas de portable à
l'époque n'ont donc vous avez dû donner
votre 0 1 c'est ça non mais franchement
assez ça vous est donné votre numéro
fixe
oui et non s'adressent ils venaient tout
le temps battu monthey quoi il était
tout en bas de chez vous ouais ouais
ouais t'as problème
zakia vous êtes venus ce soir là pour
faire une surprise à doc et je crois que
cette surprise lui fait extrêmement
plaisir mais vous êtes venus également
pour lui dire quelque chose
oui oui
à l'egypte je voulais te dire que toutes
ces années même si toi tu avais pas de
nouvelles de moi
moi j'en avais grâce à ta notoriété donc
était toujours suivi et on s'était fait
une promesse il rappelle donc s'était
fait une promesse et je voulais juste
dire que moi ma promesse veulent à tenir
c'est loin et que je t'aime c'est
toujours aimé il suffire de toi
[Applaudissements]
mes filles
sans aimer monde aucun écho temps c'est
pas nous que ça arriverait si vous êtes
resté vous allez rester copains donc
maintenant vous avez les vendre un spare
c'est vrai que vous l'avez jamais
oublier non jamais jamais le manoir
on oublie pas c'est vrai qu'on n'oublie
pas tu as quelque chose à dire à zac est
atteint oui oui en fait oui je vais
tenir notre promesse mais c'est quoi la
promesse parce que nous on n'était pas
là donc j'ai fait elle est censée quoi
qu'il arrive dans la vie toujours
toujours toujours se voir toujours
toujours recevoir jaur être ensemble
c'est à dire ayez la soie qu'il arrive
on a dit qu'on resterait l'avait
lui-même sans être là à côté de l'autre
de se protéger ses forces mystérieuses
oui franchement il
[Applaudissements]
oui il est exceptionnel c'est un être
exceptionnel
m c'est un bon sens vraiment je vous dis
je suis très heureux parce que j'avais
rarement vu bruno comme ça c'est gros
je suis content de t'avoir fait plaisir
[Applaudissements]
alors les chéris sert il
regardez issam ça se voit oui oui c'est
de l'amitié vous calmez vous il est avec
quelqu'un c'est tout le monde est d'avis
que vous êtes avec quelqu'un maintenant
acquis ajustements non non vous êtes
célibataire oui ah d'accord
[Rires]
tous montrent une vraie c'est qu'on
n'allait pas la gâcher